why does everybody keep on hiring me all
of my work is haha everything is
awesome well done Chris Miller well
thank you but he's not the only one we
should congratulate our own Jennifer Lee
has gotten a job writing and directing
at Disney oh it's nothing just the most
famous studio in the world
well I suppose now we can bring her in
on our real gamble what what gamble Oh
every time a new filmmaker comes along
we make an impossible dare to see if
they can pull it off
yes and they in turn make theirs back
really and seeing how you're the
newcomer with Disney I bet you can't
make an animated film that points out
all the faults of the past Disney films
has two female heroes one of them a
queen and have her sing a song so
popular even boys okay I like a
challenge especially in this demographic
ruled by thirteen-year-old boys they're
always the most profitable but what
about you mr. Peyton Reed what about me
if I achieve that then you have to make
a successful superhero movie where the
hero shrinks down to the size of an you
know shrinking films are box-office
poison right now what's the matter
not taking my race oh yes I'll call not
that Miller and Lord over there have the
balls to do so hey we're just as balls
he's either you yeah
prove it I bet that we could do a
product placement movie so good that we
could name the movie after the product
and nobody would care yeah and people
even be upset that it wasn't nominated
for Best Animated Feature say
mind if I play
no what why not you suck at this game
Shyamalan yeah what's this idea that you
can make tree scary
yeah it's later down the road this idea
is guaranteed to show you how talented I
am wait isn't this the one that Disney
didn't understand so you stormed out
even though they were gonna fund it
anyways what does that yes I heard about
this you said Disney didn't respect
individualism they're a bunch of
accident realize my brilliance yeah what
is this brilliance alright the main
character is named story owed not happen
she's an ancient creature called a narf
honey you can't do this and she's being
chased by scrunge but saved by Tartu tix
sure to bum down the street shouting
stuff like this oh c'mon even I'm not
that high I will show the world that I
am so good that I can make something so
silly absolutely amazing I mean what
else could happen to this movie let's
get this baby started
well may people see the happening of
Shama wands funny is so bad it's good
film I challenge them with the absolute
mad ravings of lady in the water sure
it's slower and doesn't have quite as
many silly performances but the story is
so insane so ego stroking so freakin
bizarre that if a well-known filmmakers
name wasn't attached to it yet swear was
written on the walls of a mental
institution there's so much to talk
about so let's not waste any time let's
end channel on month with my favorite
bad movie of his lady in the water who
it starts off with the backwash I mean
backstory of the seemingly simple fable
once man those in the water were linked
they inspired us man listened and it
became real but man does not listen very
well you just said they did man's need
to own everything
let him deeper into land world of man
became more violent war upon war played
out as there were no guides to listen to
well if they're so good at guiding
people how did they let this happen to
begin with a handful of their precious
young ones have been sent there are laws
that are meant to keep the young ones
safe but they are sent at great risk to
their lives but wait if there's laws to
keep them safe then why would they be a
great risk sometimes men take matters
into their own hand that's not what you
said movie represented now by Jack
Nicholson performance that you said they
were safe but now they're at great risk
so they should be in a danger should the
movie you snotty little bastard why
don't you descend with however each
amenity sucks story and saying how man
has forgotten how to listen man have
forgotten how to listen
show us the way movie we know you have
it even though in the first two minutes
you already have tons and tons of
problems people we have faith in you we
think at the Paul Giamatti is some kind
of creature tell her it's not a creature
there's no such thing as creatures a
creature is just something he can't
identify like the tone of this movie a
new tenant seems to be staying at the
cove an apartment complex Giamatti works
at
he's a movie critic named mr. Farber
Widow's D ass
now mr. Farber this is young-soon Choi
she lives with her mother in a day she's
a student at the University
hey if Shyamalan would be nice enough
maybe he'll cut to a shot that actually
shows her face nope
well at least he held out a shot for a
while that automatically equals genius
you know but not as genius as talking
directly into the camera another typical
Shyamalan trope
homes like an experiment I'm like a
scientist it's fascinating how greedy
one can get with their art scene is in
most movies these guys shots are used
sparingly to establish mood but with
Shyamalan he uses it like how the
director of Battlefield Earth uses
tilted shots weird angles sometimes
warrior dangles always brilliant we're
brands we do the brilliant dance but who
cares it's time to figure out what
stupid work this guy has because as
always any quirk no matter how stupid
always equals a developed character
let's see what we have in our kitchen
let's see what we have here um you like
hot dogs
expired water ah here we are working out
half of your body for no reason most
people say hey what's wrong with you
raging why you only work me out on one
side of your body remember it doesn't
need to make sense you just have to say
that director has a style and therefore
it's good it's the law hey hey so well
compose out there that looks
effortlessly done like there was no
effort put into it whatsoever
it's almost as good as this one of
Giamatti ending his day and the camera
slowly tilting up to reveal absolutely
no sight you know something visually
interesting there might have been nice
was even the moon like no hell no I'm
not being in this
muhr mando no but trust me it's
something just as equally ridiculous he
goes out to the pool to inspect when he
was underwater now he's not no he's back
underwater now he's not now it's out of
the water he slips he goes back into the
water tries to get out says nah and he
suddenly in his room
well the best is easy to follow us and
morph into snowstorm there does however
seem to be a wet naked woman in his room
now not this again that at least this
one's alive are you from do you feel an
awakening is that like a happening once
you just replace all your dialogue with
do you feel an inning my name is story
oh yes you heard that correctly it's
that kind of movie I have two siblings
an older sister named long story and a
younger sister named short story I have
a very honest mother we named true story
an aging father named old story a dead
grandfather named ghost story and for
some reason all of them remind me of my
two pets
cock-and-bull story what I'm trying to
say is that name is stupid so he gives
her a sure turning her into a cover
story and sleeps the night away holding
her in his arms because this really
wasn't creepy enough yet are you anyway
didn't catch that yeah you did the name
of her species is narf and not only that
they say this word all the time like
it's a totally common name if a narf
thousand nos the North has come the
madam not Norv a narf what was laughs
already taken or plunk look out we have
to save them Yin Yin yes they're on the
roof of the car pocket he blocks the
bitchy for real he tries to carry her
outside but sees a wolf waiting in the
distance
or serve the nothing which apparently
this film has an abundance of what
what's going on how can you not burst
out into laughter watching that scene
what can you even say about it
it looks like he's carrying an anorexic
Julia Roberts to their honeymoon suite
while she wants the pool to pull her
finger just before a steroid chia pet
eats them alive what is is so he decides
to ask someone who would obviously know
all about mythical creatures Rufio
could you look up the word narf
for me I'm sure you've come across them
from your adventures in Neverland
it's an he's dead bedtime story mr. Hugh
ah yeah I wouldn't insult Eastern
storytelling like that I think the
correct answer is oh that sounds like
we're from the same idiot who came up
with cypher Raige very common Eastern
name but her mother knows all about it
what are the odds and she says the narf
sorry that's gonna take some getting
used to
has to meet the chosen one so that she
can inspire it she will return with the
great he's run a Giant Eagle
they of course cut out the scene where
she ate five pot brownies before saying
this but you get the idea so Giamatti
looks for this chosen one whose story
says is a writer go again you could just
replace all the dialogue with what's
your quirk she's very good with animals
mm-hmm and your quirk - crossword
puzzles and your quirk let's make up a
witty phrase babies on the half stick
yeah she says she can't even do stoners
right that's not how a STONER screams
that's one of the rice krispies else
watching another one died
oh snap of course Giamatti is so focused
on finding a rider that he completely
overlooks the person he's known for
years that is a writer how's the riding
done what story has been ease dropping
in his diary to learn about his past the
night a man entered your home when you
were not there
he stole many things and killed your
wife and children that is when you
stopped being happy brilliant deduction
there Nancy Drew any other obvious dots
you like to connect when I hit my head
that's when my head hurts
when my butt farts us when the air
smells bad when I run in high heels
people will focus more on that rather
than how dumb the rest of the movie is
why don't you get suited up in your
proper uniform but Giamatti introduces
the writer to her and take a wild guess
who plays no I sent in that form yeah
that's right the writer who really has
lost his muse yeah take a good look
there Sean a lot that's the closest a
story you'll ever get and have seemingly
irrelevant and tedious dialogue that
seems to regurgitate nice meeting you
I'm so very happy we saw each other so
he's inspired to go write devil as
Giamatti tries to get story back home
but the grass hyena is still up we're
okay now
thank God he can't climb stairs so he
tries to get more information from the
Korean peacock who seems totally fine
interrupting her clubbing to talk fairy
tales she said only a robust rant will
break the law of that night because most
cons are afraid Fred Watts tattoo chick
oh it's Garang snarf store 2 takes these
all sound like cartoon characters
sneezing just look at your body's face
after hearing all this he's like well
hymen a bomb this whole thing reads like
a drunk mother reading a half at bedtime
story to her kid
this is a story about story but
characters name a story oh yes
yep and she is an ancient No uh-huh
yes and she's running running away from
the the meanest school scrunt
mm-hmm mm-hmm it all took place in
modern times good night well it's better
than a time she said the trees did it
you